so i've been using the s20 ultra to
record my youtube videos for the last
year how does the s21 compare to this
beast of a phone
what's going on guys my name is david
tomic and welcome back to the channel
today we're comparing the s20 ultra
against the s21 ultra
it is samsung's latest and greatest
flagship that is putting the s20 ultra's
title of greatest smartphone greatest
camera ever on a smartphone
at great jeopardy straight off the bat
it's a little sad that the s21 ultra
comes out at 150 australian dollars
cheaper than the original s20 ultra did
that means the s21
comes out at 1849 australian dollars
versus the 199 australian dollars that
the s20 is still priced at
here right now in 2021. if you have an
educational email
or a business email or a government
email here in australia
you can access that version of samsung's
store
so for example the educational samsung
store gives you about 25
off as does the government as does the
business the s20 ultra was able to be
picked up
from that store for fifteen hundred and
fifty nine dollars
whilst the s21 ultra on that store is
available for fourteen hundred
and forty nine dollars with the fifty
dollar discount that samsung offers you
for just visiting their website
now the one thing you might notice while
comparing the price tag is the fact
that the s21 ultra offers a great
variety
of storage models usually this isn't a
big deal with samsung because you have
the ability to put an sd card in
i know for example with the s20 ultra
you can put one terabyte
of sd storage straight into the s20
ultra
whilst the s21 ultra has removed this
entirely
so 128 gigs as the baseline model
probably isn't enough in my personal
experience as a youtuber you're gonna
need a little bit more
so moving up to 256 gigs which
means a price tag of about 1559
on the educational store or just under 2
000
from the stores itself now as we're
focusing on the videography elements of
these two smartphones
it is critical that we focus on the cons
of the s20 and the pros of the s21 the
s20 had
so many auto focus issues at the very
start and it was
terrible you constantly had to adjust
and make sure something was in focus
before you're able to record i knew i
recorded heaps of videos that were out
of focus
blurry i had to scrap them and re-record
them after a few months however and ever
since thankfully
the s20 ultra has had software updates
to improve
that autofocus touchwood
we haven't had any issues with the s20
ultra since
the s21 ultra comes with a laser focus
detector
very similar to that of the note 20
ultra experience
so having laser autofocus means there is
an
actual physical distance measuring
device which is able to interpret that
focus a lot better than the previous
software reiteration that was on the s20
so straight away that is a huge
difference in these two devices which
gives the s21 ultra the upper hand
both devices really promoted that 8k
video
and the 8k recording capabilities now i
only use the 4k video recording for a
very specific reason
8k recording on the s20 ultra and the
s21 ultra
uses approximately 600 megabytes per
one minute of footage now i've written
these stats down just so i don't get
them wrong and i want to make sure i get
them right
if you were to buy the gigabyte model
with
no sd card storage solutions you would
have
somewhat of a problem if you wanted to
record on 8k only so let's use this
phone as an example of everything i have
currently it is 128 gigabytes of storage
i have 92 gigabytes of storage used for
apps
downloads photos videos and of course 20
gigabytes just to run the software
if you're going to do the maths of 600
megabytes per minute that equates to 36
gigabytes per hour
which means i can only use one hour
of 8k video recording now if you're a
youtuber looking to create lots and lots
of content
one hour is nowhere near enough you're
definitely going to need
some more storage so the s21 ultra
basically means that if you buy the 128
gigabyte model
one hour of recording and that's it your
phone is full
you can basically dump that footage onto
a computer take it off
start again yes you can probably get rid
of a few apps and give
that a bit more storage but in actual
reality if you were to use your phone
unrestricted you'd probably only get
about an hour of recording now if you
put that
one terabyte sd card into the s20 ultra
which you can do on the s20 and you
can't do on the s21
you would get an additional 27.7
hours of 8k recording there's probably
no chance that you're going to go a
whole day
of recording without being close to a
laptop to dump that footage
if you need to so being able to have
almost
30 hours of recordable space on your
device
and still use your device to its full
capabilities is phenomenal
now if we backtrack and only look at the
4k video capabilities
at 30 frames a second 30 frames a second
4k
takes up 280 megabytes of storage
per one minute which equates to 16.8
gigabytes per hour
if again we use the same calculations 92
gigs of space
used through data downloads etc 128
gigabyte model
that gives you two hours of 4k video
recording
alternatively if you move up to the 256
gigabyte model
that gives you an extra 7.6 hours of
recording
whereas if you had the extra terabyte of
sd card storage you'd get
60 hours of 4k video recording so video
recording is very important to you
and storage is very important to you
you're either going to have to pay that
premium price tag for the 512 gigabyte
model
of the s21 ultra or stick with the s20
ultra for the simple fact that you have
that expandable storage
and for those fails with the s20 ultra
you can simply pop out that sd card put
a new sd card in
and keep recording you basically have no
limit
your only limit is the battery life
itself which brings us to another pretty
critical and important point
the s21 ultra might seem like the brand
new superior phone
but it has a few drawbacks so the s20
ultra in 30 minutes has the ability to
charge to 62
thanks to a 45 watt charging
capabilities whilst the s21 ultra is
limited to 25 watts of fast charging
and it can only fulfill 50 percent of
its battery life
within the first 30 minutes speaking of
charge times it's no good having a good
charger or a fast charging capability
if they don't actually include it in the
box so that price tag before
of 1849 i think it was
is actually a bit of a lie because you
need to go out and buy that additional
charger if you don't already have one
now as a youtuber you might also be
using a gimbal quite often
if you take the dji om4 for example
which is my gimbal of choice it has a
maximum payload of 230 grams
for the smartphone itself the s20 ultra
comes in at 220 grams whilst the s21
ultra comes in at 229 grams
so you're definitely putting the gimbal
at maximum payload capacity
but it is still able to be used on a
gimbal right now
there are some additional perks of the
s21 and it's the simple fact that the
screen resolution can now be used
at its best whereas the s20 is limited
and we still don't have that ability to
do so
the s21 has all the directors modes as
well as a vlogger mode where you can
record both
rear and front camera simultaneously it
also has
the s pen support which could or could
not be beneficial
to youtubers i think as a general rule
of thumb it's probably a nice little
feature to have but it's not necessary
and it is cheaper
there has been no price drop as of
recording this video
for the s20 ultra compared to the s21
ultra so if you would go out and store
and pick up either one of these two
devices the s20 would still be more
expensive so overall what's my opinion
well personally i believe if you already
have an s20 ultra
keep it for a couple more months till
some better deals come out on the s21
there is a number of deals that always
come out on samsung products especially
when the device has been out for a
little bit
and all those promotions go away for
pre-ordering if you're a youtuber
looking to do lots of studio setup
videos
and things where you have controlled
lighting and a controlled environment
i believe the s20 is phenomenal however
if you are a vlogger that's going to go
outside
constantly change camera angles
constantly be moving i think that laser
autofocus is almost a must
and it is definitely the platform and
the device of choice
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video if you did
make sure you smash that subscribe
button down below and as always i will
see you
next monday